judge's office my name is um sybil
richardson
and my family the richardson family is
awaiting on a ruling
from judge rogers regarding my husband's
matter
i am here with the brilliant
director garrett bradley thanks for
thanks for being here with me so i want
to frame this conversation
around your journey as an artist because
i think your movie time
is a work of art and i don't think you
remember this you might not
where when we first talked it was a
phone call
and you were saying i don't know whether
i want to be
a documentary filmmaker or a fine artist
do you remember this yeah vaguely
here you in this beautiful film you've
done both it is a
work of nonfiction but there's also a
work of art i'd love to hear
about your beginnings you're both your
parents were artists right
yeah yeah they're both painters my dad's
20 years older than my mom so they come
from really different they were married
for one year
[Laughter]
and they come from really different um
worlds and kind of
backgrounds but both i think are we're
interested in thinking about abstraction
from two really different spaces my mom
uses a lot of
language and a lot of words in her
paintings that are abstract
and so there's sort of this question of
of what the relationship is between
something that's literal and something
that
exists outside of that space and i think
for my dad
um abstraction was something he has very
very sort of regimented ideas about
sort of daring somebody to attach
his identity who he is as a as a black
man
to his work you know through abstraction
and i think both of them as a result of
who they were my mom being a white woman
my dad being a black man
moving through the world with their
practices presented
different opportunities and different
challenges and myself obviously being a
combination of both of them i was very i
think attuned to what i was
up against in the world you know and how
to
try to find make space for myself but
doing it in a way that was
i think inherently connected to
community that it that even if as a
painter
yes it's it's a practice of solitude but
you're so reliant on
and so in need of your community and
being in conversation with other artists
and i think for me as a filmmaker
that has been the biggest thing that has
driven me is understanding the role of
community but i
see you you know when we have these
phone calls you're in joshua tree you're
in new york
the last time we talked you were doing
the installation at the
museum of modern art with the big like
oh pan to the right and there's like
giant garrett bradley thing in the
entrance of the museum and i'm like oh
okay okay this is just another day in
garrett bradley's life but
i say that because i always see you
surrounded by artists some of them in
the non-fiction world but some of them
in the
fine art world and some of them just
artists
in the world is that important to you i
think to a certain extent
i you know i have a community of people
that are all really
invested in their own practice and what
they're doing and that we find
you know we find community in that
because i think what's so essential is
having an exchange
being able to talk with people about
what you're thinking about
and getting to understand what they're
thinking about and
coming up with new conclusions living in
that gray area that exists between you
and other people is so crucial to
pushing myself as an individual so let's
talk about how you translate that
into your work i work in non-fiction too
and i know what it's like when you show
up and you're about to shoot
everyone like everyone watching the
movies matt is in this
right in the moment but when you show up
you got boxes
and cameras and batteries and all that
kind of stuff
and there's a routine to way non-fiction
works forget the technicality of being a
director and more about
i'm going back to you as an artist how
do you approach that day
well working really in any space for me
that involves a camera
it's such a practice in honoring the
present moment
and knowing how to when i say honor it i
don't mean just like make the best use
of it but to really evoke
the greatness of it you know and those
things can be
subtle you know and i think in order to
tap
into those subtleties for me i've always
had to
to a certain extent plan a lot so that i
completely
can give myself to the chaos of of a
moment of something that's unpredictable
so you want to be open and vulnerable
just feel what's going on yeah
before the technical stuff takes over so
with time for instance
it was really important for me to think
about okay
first i always start with conversations
with people why do you want to make this
film right
what what is it what is important about
doing this and fox
and rob and the family said over and
over again our story is the story of 2.3
million american families and we feel
that our story can offer hope
and so in my mind i'm saying to myself
okay number one that is in alignment
with the intention for me as well so
that's a good thing number two
hope is kind of a vague thing but it's
clearly what's so important to them
and there's something there so how do i
how do i show hope
and like what does hope look like for
them and their family and so i think
about that a lot i spend time with the
family
and it really boiled down i think to
these three things it was
it was unity it was their ability to
stay together over the course of 21
years
it was love right and it was also their
individuality and how
who they were as individuals amidst a
system that was
trying to thwart that and so when i'm
starting the day
which of those three things are we
showing or maybe it's all three of those
things at the same time but i know
there's some kind of guiding force that
then allows me to not have to be in
control of anything but at least know to
a certain extent
that my intention is in alignment with
something that's real and that is
anchoring
why couldn't i have talked to you 30
years ago when i was starting out
i could have used this for my movie i
mean it's so beautiful and
i mean it it's like you don't start with
the technicality
and i mean for all these people who are
watching this or are
filmmakers you know it's so easy to say
well what lens do you want
where do you want to put the camera what
kind of lights do you want you know
do you want to mount in the car and all
those things take over
and what you're saying is you start with
a core intention
for your day and you want to be and also
you want to sit in that room wherever
that is a car
or fox's office and you say okay what's
going on here how do i feel this
and how's that how does that connect to
that core intention that's so beautiful
yeah and then the lens stuff is like
it's fun because it can just reinforce
the things that you
hopefully already know you know the zoom
lens for me was such a powerful
sort of realization for my practice
because it was still
but it also moved but it moved in a way
that i think
feels very very similar to what
concentration feels like
listen my story is the story of over two
million people in the united states of
america
that are falling prey to the
incarceration
of poor people and people of color it's
so interesting because all that tone
we're talking about and all the
intention
and it's interesting when people say oh
that's the movie about
incarceration i'm like well and yet that
idea
is all around it and yet it's also not
in it
how do you deal with that making it part
of the film and also
not in the film and why it was really
important and i'm i'm really
grateful to you and to concordia and to
everybody who really and to gabe
gabe's the editor yeah gabe rhodes who
cut the film for like
everyone just saying you know it's okay
to lean into the human experience it's
okay
to lean into this as a love story that
is also
deeply affected by incarceration and
that if we can do that
we can hopefully open up a portal open
up an additional additional entry point
into incarceration but from a human
experience you know
i want my man man ain't nothing else
pacifying me ain't no
further on up the road they know i think
y'all wonderful y'all doing a great job
i want my family home i want my family
together
i want my children i had a daddy and i
wanted him before
my my twins turned 18. i wish
people watching this could be have been
at this first screening at sundance
i mean people were the woman next to me
was sobbing
uncontrollably and i was sobbing too it
was so emotional
and fox and and rob and all the kids
were there
it was very brave of you not to
make it just like any other film you
wanted to make it the film you wanted to
make
i want to talk about um the scene
uh where fox finally
lets her frustration out she's at her
desk and it's a long there's a long
long take where she's patient calling
about her husband what the status is and
then
she just lets it go and it's funny i
just my wife and i are just talking
about this idea of
everyone has their story
and everyone has their truth and it felt
to me like
her truth came out success is the best
revenge
success is the best revenge i see him
like one of those little [ __ ]
children success is the best revenge
you're going to get them fox you're
going to get them you're going to show
them that they can't treat human life
this way
success is the best revenge just hang in
there because when you get them home
they're going to pay they're going to
pay they're going to pay
they go they're going on [ __ ] pay god
damn
yeah i mean i think that the i mean
shooting it in the moment for me
felt like [ __ ] yeah get it totally
understand like
been waiting for this moment right
because it's what you know
it's remarkable that she had the amount
of control that it takes
um and the amount of sort of
exceptionalism and presentation that one
has to have to just maneuver that system
right it's crucial for people to
understand i think what it takes on a
day-to-day basis
and the release as you said is the truth
but so is the presentation so is the
control
to a certain extent totally and i do
feel like for those who haven't seen the
film
there is that by the time that moment
comes out
you as an audience are as frustrated as
she is yeah
and so you've earned that moment and you
you and gabe had to build to that moment
yeah exactly and that is so much of the
challenge of what we do i think as
filmmakers
is like how to mimic the real world in
that way you know
like how do we actually create scenes
and scenarios where
we understand the broader context even
again in the specificity of any moment
we understand these larger ideas
even if it's something that's super
intimate and that's not explicit in any
kind of way
it is beyond anything i could have
imagined you've made
a beautiful work of art and i'm so
grateful
that you made it that that movie is out
there in the world you are
a brilliant artist and a wonderful
filmmaker and
um thank you for doing this conversation
thank you davis thank you so much thank
you to you
guys all for recording this and be safe
bye my twins will be 18 next month
[Music]
18 years old when their daddy got
sentenced i was um
three months pregnant they have
absolutely
no idea about
what it means to have a father in their
house
what fathers even do
[Music]
you